Here's a funny voicemail we received.
Our voicemail line, of course, is
two one nine two David P. A.. This caller is
asking, is Rudy Giuliani on the basis of his
recent covid diagnosis, sort of like
Typhoid Mary? Take a listen to this.
Hi, David, this is Gary from Oregon again, you
ever consider that Rudy Giuliani was seen around
as Typhoid Mary to mess up all of these
states, Arizona, Nevada, blah, blah, blah?
In their government so that they
had to close down or shut down.
I wouldn't put it past Donald Trump, and
he's not my president, yeah, I wouldn't
put it past Trump morally.
This idea of, hey, maybe
if we get Rudy covid positive and send him
around and shut down state legislatures,
maybe it'll interfere with electoral votes being
formally voted on on December 14th. It's number
one. The timing of it doesn't make sense. Rudy's
been flying around for a month doing this, and he
likely was only contagious as of last Thursday.
Now, he did by exposing the Arizona legislature,
get the Arizona legislature shut down. But no, I
think, number one, the timing doesn't make sense.
Number two, I don't think they're really that
organized. And number three, I don't think it
even would plausibly impact the December 14th
electoral vote because it doesn't really depend on
state legislatures. I mean, it would theoretically
depend on state legislatures if they want to try
to interfere and send different electors. It
doesn't appear anybody's going to do that. So
morally, you're completely right. I wouldn't
put it past Trump, but it requires too much
organization for thought and it's not really a
good plan. Anyway, we have a great bonus show
for you today. Congress is daring Donald Trump to
veto their defense spending bill. Where is that
fight going to end up? The foushee effect has
led to medical school applications jumping
18 percent during the pandemic. Very interesting.
And Donald Trump's attorney general, William Barr,
days after there were rumors that Trump may
fire BA, is reportedly himself considering
resignation before the end of Donald Trump's
term. What would that achieve anyway at this
late stage of the game? We will discuss all of
those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Get instant access by signing
up at Join Pakman Dotcom.